well here's nola getting ready for his
third start this month as a nine earned
run average over the first two starts in
september it's given up nine runs in
nine innings yeah as you said i mean
even the last three starts he's only
really averaged about four and two
thirds and that's just not aaron nola
like and he's got to figure out a way to
to get through five innings and pitch
stronger into the middle innings and
through the to the end of the game
beauty there over the inside corner
blackman rung up
the tailing fastball to get out number
two absolutely freezes blackman on a
terrific pitch so two away and here's
trevor story who's armored in each of
the last couple of nights here
right there for a paul third strike
fastball at the knees and he got him
looking
so a couple of k's there for arinola to
start things
25-year-old rookie right-hander ryan
feltner
ready to make his second big league
start he's probably got some butterflies
again here today oh no question
especially with the way he performed
against the atlanta braves only like two
and two thirds he did not pitch very
well five hits
gave up three home runs in that game
siguri hitting a couple of ticks at 297
under 300
the home run in the series is 12th he
has driven home 50
02 pitch swag and a miss foul tipped
held on to by diaz and it's a strikeout
for ryan feltner it's his first major
league strikeout as well two on two out
for rio muto
line to the left field rio muto turns on
one it hops to the fence and the
phillies are on the board
scores harper to third it's one nothing
there's the bet coming to life for jt
rio mutu as we go to the second ryan
mcmahon will lead off for the rockies
there's the hard stuff got him looking
three straight backwards k's for nola
he's working that fast ball down in the
zone i mean he can be really effective
and and you get a lot of life down there
as well marinola back out for a third
inning of work he's looked very solid
three strikeouts over the first couple
of frames and just one base runner
allowed
there's a big curveball from nola four
strikeouts through the first eight
batters he has faced got it working
early
one out and here's ryan feltner this
will be his first big league at bat out
of the count nota whines and delivers
the one two breaking balls swinging
a couple of uncle charlie's for the
strikeouts here in this third inning and
that'll bring up rymel tapia hit the
ball in the air to left his first time
one two pitch swing miss got him with a
fastball how about nola strikes out the
side in order on 11 pitches charlie
blackman to face nola a strikeout
looking in the first for charlie
minolta's two strike pitch breaking ball
swinging a mess another great curveball
from nola he's gotten blackman twice
that's seven punch-outs two outs and
let's see if nola can help himself
line drive nola base hit rounding third
real muto and he'll score
nola delivers indeed the phillies double
the lead thanks to the pitcher hey
sometimes you gotta take business into
your own hands and that's exactly what
you get out of aaron
ryan mcmahon he leads off against nola
for that just up and in the 200th strike
out of the season for aaron nola
then number eight here this afternoon he
has the board with colton welker coming
up welker hits this pretty well to right
harper battling the sun can't see it it
drops next to him
and
it'll go as a single to its first and
second so garrett hampson see if the
rockies can take advantage and this
ball's lifted to fairly deep left field
garrett hampson has given the rockies
the lead
a three-run home run on a breaking ball
and the rockies run in front 3-2 10th
homer of the year for hampson aaron nola
has given up now 24 home runs on the
year you make a mistake to garrett
hampson he is more than capable
of doing what he just did man still just
one out of the inning pinch hitter is
going to be rio ruiz batting for gilbert
there's a strikeout swinging on a
fastball ruiz goes down nine k's for
nola here's tapia nola probably can't
wait to get himself back into that
dugout
and he will with a curve ball
second time in the game that he strikes
out the side bringing up bryce harper
walking a strikeout
this is fought off a fastball to left
and a diving catch made by tapia
stealing a hit maybe a double
from bryce harper tapia got a great jump
as you mentioned times the dive
perfectly tracks it all the way into the
glove connor brockton takes over from
nola here in the sixth with one out
trevor's story is the batter and he's
over two today 3-2
to second and what a catch by segura
it's going to be a double play
gene segura flashing the leather trevor
story hit a seed but gene segura was in
the right spot kind of a pinch hitter
here for the phillies it's matt joyce
big spot to come right back into the
fire huh runner at third two out
down and in it gets away it'll tie the
game good oh spiked a fastball
a wild pitch brings in rio muto it's
three
well garrett hampson put a good swing on
a curveball from aaron nolan his last at
bat and hit it over the left field wall
with two of his
teammates aboard diaz over at first
still with two down now
in the air deep left again
near the wall is joyce he leaps can he
get it now god
himself done it again
two-run homerun hampson 5-3 colorado
hamptons had some big days already in
his young big league career
given the circumstances and the score
i don't think anything better so far
than this sunday afternoon
in philadelphia
three-run homer two-run homer each time
to give the rockies the lead bryce
harper leads off against chassis
harper's reached once today he walked
back in the first
driven to right field back blackman all
the way to the wall another one bryce
harper
then we've got a one run game in the
eighth
number 32
five to four rockies i gotta tell you
this
young man has just been electric over
the last half of this season gets out
out of there in a hurry and that's a
one-run game
you could see that reaction after he saw
that go over the fence bryce knows how
important this game is to the phillies
in their playoff hopes as we start the
ninth inning here with elias diaz in the
box
ripped again left side gregorius to the
backhand dive
got him at first what a play basically
throwing from his knee
to throw a pee over to first base and he
gets diaz who does not run well but was
running hard right out of the box and
that is a tremendous play here comes
andrew mccutchen
who has struggled
so mightily
against right-handed pitching this year
look back at second here's the pitch
swinging a ground ball deep short
backhand pick by story throws off
balance to first it's high welker got
the tag down on him leaping in the air
colton welker has made another
error-saving play at first base philly's
down to their final out and it'll be
odoodle herrera this could be the end
this is on the ground a second routine
play ball game over and the rockies take
three of four in philadelphia